merci monsieur le Président je dois dire
que c'est tout de même assez étonnant la
séquence et le donc le débat intéressant
que nous avons ce matin parce que bon
nous avons des désaccords sur le projet
de retraite qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui
on a eu un débat intéressant sur la
capitalisation mais pourquoi le
gouvernement a-t-il voulu retenir ce qui
n'était pas dans son texte initial dans
un projet de loi initial la version qui
nous est soumise aujourd'hui
bénéficie d'un ajout ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure proposé par Marc Ferracci
qui est un très très très proche du
président de la République sur la
retraite à points et là comment dire on
voit un gouvernement qui est quand même
on va dire un petit peu en difficulté
sur cette réforme des retraites on se
souvient 2019 on se souvient des
manifestations la crise covid formidable
a permis le retrait de ce texte on se
souvient de l'âge pivot
de finalement de ceux qui se sont
trouvés victimes de cette réforme
monsieur de le voir dont on a plus
entendu parler depuis monsieur
pietrazewski dont moi-même j'avais
oublié qu'il avait joué un rôle dans
cette affaire
Édouard Philippe qui lui-même n'avait
pas le même avis que le Président de la
République sur ce sujet mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont venus faire dans cette
galère
[Musique]